a little comfort food so let's talk
comfort food did you know unfortunately
it's not as good for you as you might
think of course you know you get
depressed eat some waffles eat some
pancakes you go to mcdonalds etc etc you
think you're going to feel better after
new studies are proving you actually
will feel worse now I guess in some ways
that's not surprising you're putting
crap in and you're going to feel like
crap but then another way we all do this
right when you get depressed you what do
you do what do you turn to a little
chocolate I have I have a comfort ometer
and it goes you know not bad cozy
diabetes the American goal for me is to
eventually just be this bloated sphere
with tiny limb buds and a tiny sea of
facial features on the top of the egg
and and I'm being wheeled around in some
sort of wall-e rascal cart to stores
with an opening that will permit me
indoors yeah and that's that to me is
American comfort right there I
definitely sounds like American comfort
what is your American comfort I've been
to some diners with you in the past so
you can't lie to me here I I do I the
fast food I'm trying to get away from
the fast food right now but it's always
sugar with me sugars the comfort for me
yeah and it really it doesn't last long
it you know the idea of it I think is
what lifts your mood and then you eat it
and yes you're right you feel like crap
because you just put crap into your body
and then you worry about you know how
many calories you just yeah i mean it's
it's a vicious cycle it's like anything
else now i know that you tweeted last
night that you went to in and out burger
I dinner and you know I've only been
here for about five weeks so I've gaunt
in and out several times and to me that
feels but it literally feels better in
my body than McDonald's but at the end
of the day is that just completely and
that's just the way we rationalize
things well I think they have a slightly
less msg and everyday use real potatoes
and then real tater reopen to what is
like whatever Donald's potatoes oh
they're like that they're not even
potatoes they like they change mature
extruded something or other yeah Lisa
denied you see them put the potato in
and go boy yeah and the potato comes at
the bottom and that just that process
makes you feel better at least it's a
little the steps in between the food and
me there are a few less steps where as
McDonald's I don't even know if potatoes
were ever even a thought in the french
fry I'm really not sure yeah is this a
little bit like the previous topic like
the oil like we're so addicted to it we
just can't we can't stop well there are
there was someone that would wrestle you
to the ground MMA style if you were if
you were to warn them that aspartame was
not good for them because they're going
I finally got off sugar onto a spare a
team and now you tell me this you're
taking my one last thing away and that's
how the brain structures all this you
tell the good people when s is it a
sparrow tamer esperate esperate can you
tell the people what it is because I'm
on a stage race against it it's a Dre
bad chemical that gives you all kinds of
kidney problems and it's in diet it's in
every diet and lots of things and
nutrasweet is another nice way to hide
what it is in the word nutria yeah like
there's nutrition in it yeah very clever
but you have our use of utter BS yeah
would you rather go down with some high
fructose corn syrup then I used my
chemical her in my tea in the morning I
mean that's you know if I'm gonna add
sugar if you're gonna add a sweetener
i'm gonna add honey or actual sugar to
it to it yeah if i'm gonna go you know
and have some crap then you know you get
what you get with that you get the
high-fructose stuff but you know the
thing about comfort food is that this
this it's so funny about the study
because if you just pay attention to
yourself when you're eating this stuff
you will you don't need something
because he is it's like you know it's
like it's like the alcoholic with the
alcohol you know it's like oh I need a
drink I need a drink and then you have
it and it's like okay well I feel good
for 10 minutes or my 20 minutes or my
buzz or whatever but next day yeah 20
minutes and the scientists goes is 20
minutes enough yeah yeah is that is that
what you're you know is it worth it well
speaking of the drinking policy
what'swhat's both your drinking policy
is it is it the glass and a half as they
tell you to have every night or a man
can have to I think right a woman should
have I got it on Christmas Day I feel
really yeah I I had been self-medicating
choosing to self-medicate
and you know instead of some sort of
antidepressant I was using that which it
is a depressant but it I feel great it's
not like I'm going to quit forever and I
wasn't like drunk or you know like
stumbling or anything like that but I
just feel like my metabolism doesn't
need that in my brain doesn't need that
yes I'll have a glass of champagne into
celebration or something like that but
you know it and I think people you know
you it's really about paying attention
to what is happening in your own body
but we don't pay attention to anything
in this country yeah Rick what's here
what's your drinking Paolo I put it
behind me after mom passed away and so
uh I was doing a little grieving about
that and then I looked at what I do when
I grieve and have a look at myself in
the process and you know figured it out
yeah it's tough though to be in the
comedy world sure I mean can be around
pouring like fountains everywhere around
you yeah but look at you two I that both
never looked better can I just don't
forget bonobos calm is the official
outfitter of the Ruben report they've
got great new slim fit shirts I've never
felt sharper enter code trr 20 for
twenty percent off your first purchase